[Applaudissements]
m
ces chansons qui ont marqué les années
70 c'est entre autres avec rivers of
babylon sur un rythme naya bingi que
jimmy cliff a débuté son concert hier
soir une chanson populaire des
communauté rasta dont les paroles sont
tirés de la bible ce titre figurait sur
la bande originale du film the harder
they come en 1972 où tout tout de suite
en france dans lequel le reggaeman
jamaïcain tenait le premier rôle
[Musique]
et
face à jimmy cliff près de 900 personnes
une salle comble au début un peu trop
sage comme en communion jusqu'à ce que
le reggaeman international demande à son
public de se lever
charest
g
va pas changer
[Musique]
jimmy cliff pour vous ça redescend poids
mon enfance et puis plein d'autres
choses
c'est cet en-cas pensa pour ne rater ça
adp alors non
les revoilà
le reggae
siegel mais je m'amuse vraiment fous
qu'eux
la maman et on est toutes les deux
cette image c'est vraiment celle qui
reflète totalement l'ambiance de ce
concert avec un public âgé
essentiellement de plus de 50 ans mais
avec malgré tout de nombreux jeunes
à 71 ans au bout de 56 ans de carrière
jimmy cliff rassemble encore toutes les
générations
[Musique]